potable à cause d'un garçon qui à cause
d'une fille ou d'un garçon a déjà perdu
son meilleur ami
ah bah vous en fait je crois mais si ce
nom mais aujourd'hui olive autrui c'est
je pense à vous tout de suite c'est
possible voilà bah vous nous raconterez
tout à l'heure pour moi mais je les
retrouve après mais c'est vrai qu'il
était sensé perdu s'est pas perdue genre
dans la rue après on l'a retrouvé un nom
mais on bosse et on s'est fâché pendant
deux ans quand même nom là parce qu'il
sort avec une il sortait avec une fille
dont j'étais amoureuse secrètement je
n'ai pas dit parce que j'ai vu qu'il ait
jamais laisser la priorité c'est lui qui
met le premier a avoué qu'il avait des
sentiments pour elle du coup je lui ai
pas dit j'en avais aussi il est sorti
avec elle ça durait qu'un week-end c'est
roger hanin est sacré alexandre et on
est sorti avec elle un week-end
seulement et après ils sont séparés dans
le jury dit je suis désolée de tenir
mais comme ç'a duré qu'un week-end je
pense que je suis en droit de tenter
aussi ma chance
imedi dehors des questions elle est à
moi j'étais à toi tu l'as eu deux jours
pour amar faculté laurendeau nîmes et
metz et longwy les chiens du cou et m'a
dit tu choisis entre elle et moi j'ai
choisi l est ont ça me fâche et pendant
deux ans et ça a été une très belle
histoire d'amour et on s'est retrouvés
oui deux ans parce qu'après il avoué
qu'il était gay donc du coup ça peut
très bien merci
alors delphine vous avez parlé d'un
instant je veux pas prendre de risques
de chute après une histoire pour rien
[Rires]
parce que là c'est l'ego 10 heures de
merde c'est bon 19h24 elle est un peu
coquine oui on a décimé avec avec les
mots les mots qui sont les bons mots
alors j'ai un ami qui rencontrent
quelqu'un en boîte de nuit qui est très
beau pour le coup et à la il sort un peu
avec quelques semaines et puis un jour
ils ont clairement boîte de nuit
ouais ça lui excuse moi ça va donner en
parle toujours à peu près excuse moi
est-ce que tam la pop commenta je suis
juste savoir enfin tout démontre choisi
vous avez raison mais vous avez raison
lui dire sur les routes
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais pu sortir pour l'histoire de
cinq minutes tu nous as là dès le début
d'émission mais c'est un truc qu'on peut
pas laisser allez retrouver votre ami
non comblés par souvent on qu'on fait
nous ils le rencontrent en boîte de nuit
puis me dit tiens il est mignon et tout
ça na na na na qu au bout de trois
jeunes offre est ce que tu peux
l'essayer avec moi ce que tu me dis ce
que tu en penses
bon mais alors là on n'a rien compris la
presse c'est là que c'est un petit peu
coquin donc j'accepte gentiment comme
c'est mon ami on vous fait un plan à
trois voix là on fait un plan à plein
championnat j'appelle un chat
il m'arrivait pagezy de questions
portent beau varois et il se trouve que
pendant plan à trois son pote à un kiff
sur moi nous sommes malheureux alors que
mon ami lui commencé à tomber amoureux
de l'autre malheureusement il prenait
des risques aussi bah oui mais à l'aï
volé mon avis parce quand je ne sais pas
que je l'espère mais c'est vrai que
souvent d'accord voilà experts hommes
avaient en fait vous avez fait un double
contrôle technique c'est tout le peuple
veut le véritable échec c'est plutôt
midas le banc
[Applaudissements]
ouais mais bien pu aussi il aurait donc
l'histoire
taryn commandes à cames en bas du cou
jusqu'à cette semaine on a voulu mon
pote mona voulu et puis du coup on s'est
fâché pendant un an
non mais c'est vrai qu'on prend les amis
de la palud pas parce que j'ai un bon
sens que je peux en une fois je peux te
dire tu vas à ça ira pas loin où ça ira
loin
l'accord est le sens de sa d'accord
alors vous êtes c'est pas magique s'est
jamais besoin les courtes mais qu'une
bonne conclusion à la fin c'est vrai
alors eh ben je vais vous dire je vous
jure
si votre histoire est pourri non elle
après tout vous dire je vais prendre
quelques en otage si votre histoire mais
pourri jean michel maire ne rentre plus
toutes les missions c'est ça aussi c'est
un petit peu vous êtes un piano seul
dossier donc si l'espoir est pourri ne
rentre plus
on va d'abord écouter parce que j'ai une
autre question oui oui vous êtes sûr à
moi je suis sur wii prenez pas le risque
c'est pas parce que vous déjà vous êtes
en cdd d'un an encore adcenter en dari
lancée vous j'ai 17 ans on part pour un
week end d'ailleurs il ya 45 ans quoi on
récolte sa basse et je la connais depuis
longtemps de cela et qui est sorti avec
un joueur de foot que je connaissais
déjà
c'est vrai j'ai 17 ans j'ai un petit ami
je suis en première et on part en
week-end avec des copains des copines et
on va à la campagne solo il ya les
parents d'une copine à la campagne oui
c'est mon anniversaire
oui on est censée fêter mon anniversaire
et j'ai un gros gâteau avec des bougies
alors au moment et là au monde d'arriver
au moment de souffler les bougies
je ne trouve plus mon petit copain je
croyais je vais aller le chercher
donc je le cherche partout il est jeté
à voir donc je cherche mon petit copain
partout partout partout partout partout
et là vous le redit oui je ne retrouve
pas 5 minutes 10 minutes 15 minutes et
l'âge de lancer de nains tempérament
j'ai lancé j'ai lancé une alerte
enlèvement on le retrouve mon petit
copain avec mon meilleur ami en train de
se faire des bisous aux foires et
jardins donc un fond du jardin
meilleures amies filles non garcia sont
des bisous enfin d'essayer
quel bien béni aïssi dit hannon vas-y
bah ça va c'est eux qu'on souffler la
bougie finale
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
disons que ça
tu vas faire 15 minutes de faciale tu va
les sortir tous à vous la connaissez
raconté rapidement autre histoire
non me raconter rapidement votre
histoire
bah bah j'ai eu une petite siègeront
pendant quelques années et j'ai une
petite un petit dose pendant quelques
années ces rapaces et et un jour ma
meilleure amie m'a dit désolé je suis
tombée amoureuse de cela ouais et en
plus sa meilleure amie je peux le dire
ou pas vous aviez tatoué sont donc sur
vous sur votre barre toujours
ouais c'est ça et en fait maintenant
j'ai plus votre meilleure amie beth a
plus le maintien la ville s'appelait
matip maintenant faux faux faux enlevé
ben vous mettez matou hervé mathoux tête
s'est pas fait un truc quoi et donc ça y
est c'est la vie j'en veux à personne
célèbre nom mais elle va très bien mais
nous on veut pour cette histoire merci
oui il y avait une histoire mais après
les trucs de dingue qu'on a entendu je
sais pas si j'aurai alors ali parce que
dans un instant y aura l'histoire de
delphine wespiser alors allez-y on tient
une à part celle là si l'histoire est
bonne tout le monde revient si
l'histoire est mort et je vous jure on
fait l'émission comme ça on fait une
émission à trous le soleil se couche sur
la jetée de brighton
[Applaudissements]
le soleil se couche
ajouter le brighton et alors nous sommes
dans les années 90 et je me cherche un
peu senti mentalement basse et aux
beaudottes vous à toi aussi tu es
tranquille et l'été avec un copain tous
les étés on part en vélo en angleterre
on prend le ferry le callet foxton et
karine ferri n'est weir le ferry et
après on va se promener dans le sud de
l'angleterre
pro vélo ou vélo les deux avec votre
pote les deux avec mon pas comment
françois bon soin et le problème c'est
que c'était mais il doit rejoindre sa
petite amie
il n'était pas en couple depuis
longtemps mais sortaient ensemble dans
le sud est on arrive aux ferries et là
il dit j'en peux plus je rentre le vélo
c'est trop dur je suis malade il fait
demi tour dans le lot moi je dis je
continue je suis pas homme à abandonner
non j'irai avoir moi même ta copine com
qui rapporte ces s'en fout de vous voir
vous allez voir
apparemment je vais donc bifurquer vers
la gauche et j'arrive vers brighton
aulas je la mets pas tant qu'elle est
mauvaise et une française elle était
baby sitters serveuse en angleterre 3 à
blé alors c'était car au look les rg un
doute je crois que c'est carole ça fait
maintenant mais je crois que c'est
carole carnacois et donc il me dit où la
retrouver ou album j'y vais et je lui
dis je suis désolé à l'époque avait pas
de portable tout début des années 90
10la retrouve suis désolé françois pas
pu dire je suis là et où elle dit bah
c'est pas grave on voit un café et on va
sur la jetée de brighton et elle m'a dit
si tu plonges dans l'eau je t'embrasse
non mais oui moi j'étais un peu novice
en la matière le tuer je voulais passer
barras et vous
comme ça vous allez plonger dans l'eau
ça fait réfléchir qu'est ce que je fais
bah oui manolo appelé direct je plonge
alors ouais bah rien est parti je sais
alors j'étais lui je me ferais tout
petit
hélas à la chute j'ai sorti elle m'a
embrassé c'était divin
non alors elle m'a plaqué tout de suite
après j'ai pu revue et non la fille et
mon ami non week c'est horrible sans
rien fait a rien fait d'autre non
bon alors ça va à quoi alors delphine
wespiser ça va être beau oui alors alors
vous rappelle que vous avez oui le poids
de l'émission et des mines sur vos
épaules
si même si je voulais de 8,6 une
histoire est pourri il rentre plus les
3l et termine 6e c'est un con ils
rentrent chez eux et c'est vous qui
allez payer autant veut dire en pareille
arrive à partir des enfants il va devoir
faire des entrées en boîte de nuit de
roger juste d'acter une vaste be there
on a perdu trois personnes dans
l'émission il y avait ici jean michel
maire y avait ici je ne sais plus
comment s'appelle mais chez kaze montiel
merci il y avait ici mathieu delormeau
si votre histoire est pourri on rappelle
le thème de l'histoire c'est qu' à cause
d'une fille ou d'un garçon a déjà perdu
son meilleur ami tout ça pourquoi parce
que le film s'appelle à cause des ti à
cause des filles ou des garçons
bien entendu on a bossé ça ne tombe pas
du ciel
ah non au que non delphine
marc-antoine ça va j'ai bien fait de
venir mme delphine on va écouter votre
histoire
oui si votre histoire est pourri les
autres chroniqueurs ne rentreront pas si
votre histoire fait le job
ah oui alors là c'est humain qu'est ce
que je gagne je vous le dire fait quoi
ce soir rien on va vous faites quelque
chose à quoi
excusez moi d'être de la police vous
verrez j'organiserai un dîner entre vous
et un des chroniqueurs avec est payé par
ma personne bien entendu à me ramènerait
la mode et je fais rien mais alors déjà
en toute chose si je peux me permettre
il faut définir qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que c'est une histoire pourrait aussi
vous inquiétez pas on va tout
[Rires]
pauline ado débat je voudrais dire une
chose c'est que donne dans le titre à
cause des filles et à cause d'eux autres
faux xviiie siècle ça voulait dire grâce
à à à et le titre du film donc le pont
du force va être certainement ça c'est
grâce aux filles que à à lagord les
jugulaires non madame on y sort ce pas
tout à fait ça en fait donc alors vous
pouvez dire tout de suite je ne la
raconte pas et je rentre moi même chez
moi
la nommer jean-louis m'a dit pendant la
pub qu'il a déjà commander un taxi pour
rentrer donc donc je pose les bases donc
j'ai 16 ans d'accord c'est en alsace
dans ma région et puis j'ai une
meilleure amie depuis dix ans c'est
votre meilleure amie oui et j'ai 16 ans
donc où la pluie est ma meilleure amie
c'était ma meilleure amie toujours pour
toi mais c'est le genre de fille quand
on est à l'adolescence on l'aiment
tellement qu'on a un qu'on pense qu'on
est amoureux on est on est fusionnelle
vraiment l'agent de filet qui en fait
des jaloux à mi parcours vous
n'intéressez que maxime gagnon mauvaise
le mariage c'est vachement intéressant
c'est une amitié qu'on appelle
fusionnelle et donc à cet âge là donc
les premiers amours un jour alors qu'on
est con et tout le temps tout le temps
ensemble elle me dit bah voila j'ai un
nouveau chéri enfin j'ai un shérif et là
se pose en moi la question le dilemme
c'est à dire qu'il va me piquer ma
meilleure amie sur est donc là je
développe
[Applaudissements]
je suis d'ailleurs à une ruche chaque bd
r ça va du rouleau et donc à ce
moment-là 16 ans je développe comme
excuse à miss usa canada présente
toujours aimé la faire poser tout s'est
passé très vite
alors oui donc du coup je deviens
jalouse en fait de de ce petit copain et
un jour je lui ai dit écoute nous on
était bien ensemble maintenant tu as ton
copain je te demande de choisir
je vous demande toujours à vue donc j'ai
demandé ma meilleure amie de choisir
entre sa meilleure amie et son petit
copain
et devinez qui elle a choisi son petit
copain son petit copain haut et moins
d'actifs
je rassure juste pour assurer et espère
c'est pas la fin de l'histoire ça non et
non et donc ma conclusion arrive donc
effectivement ça fait dix ans qu'on ne
se parle plus et dingue
et voilà cette histoire je me suis juré
et je j'ai appris les choses c'est que
je ne suis plus du tout chahloul même
pas du tout petit peu en amitié ou en
amour et donc c'est là que j'ai envie
dit quelque chose
faut l'avouer alors ils m'ont demandé de
prendre vos affaires s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît non mais je vous le dis
vous qui telle aventure et ma sentence
est irrévocable
vous prenez votre sac à dos prenez vous
alizée le temps de la fusion ba merci
dit on pour appellera le temps de la pub
[Applaudissements]